Star Trek 90210 or Star Trek Academy as
some people call it the Star Trek that
nobody really wants but that Tony Nome
one of the writers and voice of Becket
from lower decks has been talking about
a little bit more Star Trek honesty I
feel oh thanks I'm going to take off oh
right after this very important meeting
welcome to SRE your scii TV and movie
channel
[Music]
I did a video a couple of days ago
talking about Jonathan fraks and him
talking about Star Trek and him saying
that there's this Bittersweet feeling he
had with the success of strange new
worlds that generally everyone seemed to
like it and he just thought you know
people kept saying that this was the
Star Trek we wanted the Star Trek we
deserved sort of implying that the Star
Trek that came before it Star Trek
Discovery and card seasons one and two
in particular were maybe not and he said
that that was a little bit Bittersweet
for him because he'd worked on those
projects now Tony Newsome has been
talking about her role as a writer for
Star Trek 902 on our star Star Trek
Academy I keep doing that I don't know
why I'm want to dance in your
blood one of the things she says is this
is just a lovely group of people that um
the show Runners who is going to be
kurtzman and another person whose name
I've forgotten um kurtzman and let's see
if that's still curtzman in 12 monstein
but anyway um just got a lovely bunch of
people together she did talk about how
normally in Hollywood there's a bunch of
psychopaths but somehow they've managed
to get a just a bunch of sweeties
together what is what no no no laughing
I was making fun of you not with you but
the one thing she did talk about was how
they have basically Cannon Police and
she actually called herself a deputy
Cannon Police now why did she mention
that and I'm going to read between the
lines here a little bit
because peard season 3 didn't actually
mess with Cannon too much I don't think
but they did make a fair few mistakes
with continuity and stuff peard season 1
and two was illogical but again I don't
think messed around with Cannon too
much Discovery spat in the eye and poked
it in the belly button
um they completely ignored Canon they
completely went random at times um it
was it was almost funny um how much they
just thought have went ah Canon Canon
SCH mannon who cares strange new worlds
has carried on that tradition they just
do it better and I would say they've got
around it with a few technicalities here
and there things that were maybe implied
they fudged and even though they maybe
haven't really destroyed Cannon anywhere
not like Discovery did they've they
they've definitely seriously broken a
few rules or bent a few rules very
heavily so yeah and it's been noticed by
the fans the fans have mentioned it so
what is T Newsome talking about I think
she's obviously on social media she's
obviously talked about these things
she's obviously seen some of the
comments about Star Trek 90210 and how
they damn I did it again didn't I and
and how people are Maybe not massively
excited about this project um they
talked in the in the article as well
about how this is going to be aimed at a
younger generation it's going to be you
know at starle Academy so anything is
possible I would actually say it's at
starle Academy so no that's not true
it's at starle Academy so learning and
stuff is possible and that's about it
it's still going to be like a school
isn't it so yeah I think they've limited
themselves a little bit um but that it's
going to be aimed at a a younger
demographic basically in the similar way
the discovery was and I think I think we
are even though we don't have the
details yet it does seem very obvious to
be honest that Star Trek Academy is
going to be based straight after
discovery in the 34th Century 32nd
Century don't really care that it's
going to be the new starf Academy that's
obvious been mentioned in Discovery once
or twice
so why do I think she's mentioned Canon
police because they've seen the comments
they've realized that they've messed
with Canon
repeatedly something actually that lower
decks even though it's a comedy show and
supposed to be you know less serious
doesn't do actually respects Canon
really really well um but they say
saying that a lot of the writers are
really hardcore now in the writer room
for um Star Trek Academy see I can do it
um and that they're taking Cannon really
really seriously Cannon Police like she
says now I hope hope that's
true because it has got to a point of
being almost a joke with Star Trek that
they just ignore Cannon whatever they
like I mean I've joked about you know
characters just turning up that are dead
and saying well you know Discovery who
cares you know the whole thing with Kirk
in strange new Worlds at the moment is
just annoying I mean how many different
excuses are they going to have for Kirk
to appear on the Enterprise next time in
season 3 it's just going to be I forgot
my wallet so I come and get it or you
know I had a dentist appointment and
I've been spent so long on the
Enterprise now my dentist is now here I
I just I it's it's it's getting Beyond a
joke I also think the longer strange new
wols goes on the more they're going to
step on Cannon but let's hope not I
think we forgive it a lot with strange W
is because we love the characters so
much so we just forgive it um I know I
do which is why I don't that's why I
don't forgive Discovery because I don't
like the show so I don't discover my mom
harder onc Discovery um but yeah so Star
Trek Academy talking about these things
I just think it's again another example
of one of the actors one of the writers
just being honest and Tony Newsome is
honest she she she's been a comedian
she's written comedy sketches and things
she is quite forthright in her opinions
and she does come out in interviews and
she is honest I need someone to make me
some me what am I supposed to do I I
don't know these guys do what you do
best I need a dangerous half solution
that breaks our Fleet codes and totally
pisses me off so I think reading between
the lines here they are talking about
how look we know we've messed up and
we're trying to do better we're trying
to really keep on top of Cannon and keep
it making sense this is part of a big
really reset for Star Trek over the last
couple of years three or four years
maybe I think where they have
consciously tried to move away from the
JJ Abrams up of the first couple
seasons of Discovery and move back
towards Star Trek we actually understand
she actually says there's a lot of
conversation in here about it being
treky it feeling like Star Trek
something that Discovery just doesn't
however much it
tries I actually saw a rod rodenburgh
interview Jee roden's kid um on the
shutle Pod show a couple of months ago
and he basically said the same thing and
I can't help but feel if the people at
secret hideout are basically Wheeling
these out they're going for an interview
they're getting fed a few lines maybe
like say mention Canon police mention
that we're doing this mention that we're
doing that I just think that um it
really is interesting that these things
keep getting mentioned now I just want
to see them actually put their money
where their mouth is they actually do it
that would be brilliant no more massive
brakes of Cannon would be brilliant I
mean even last Ser of strange new worlds
they completely wrote the car rewrote
the the K character I mean come on
um Bend rules here and there if for a
reason fine but don't break them and
don't make them obvious anyway so yeah I
think there's more honesty coming out of
secret hideout and I think that that is
a good thing because they've been
working really hard over the last three
years to try to get Star Trek back to
something we actually recognize as Star
Trek and let's hope they keep
going now there's a lot of big changes
is come in for Paramount in the next
couple of years I suspect because of
massive business decisions go check out
my other videos when I'm talking about
that and that could affect Star Trek
massively let's hope though that this
team that I actually think is doing
really interesting stuff at the moment
are allowed to carry on even though I
really don't want to have to watch Star
Trek Academy I know 2 and0 I'm not
interested but I'll keep an open mind
cuz Hey it might be better than I think
but guys get into the coms what you
think is Trek 902 damn it I did it again
is that something you care about is it a
show that you are willing to give a
chance to or is it thinking H this is
going to be more crap I really I'm just
happy discoveries ending and it just
needs to end and move on to other things
like Legacy that' be good or do you
actually think no I've quite like
Discovery I'm quite looking forward to
seeing what they're going to do Star
Trek Academy it's something they've been
trying to do for years so finally we
might actually get to see something
it'll be something a bit different
exciting get into the comments and tell
me exactly what you think if you are new
to the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out you never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
for Premier first and you can go to c.co
do.uk which is our dedicated website
where we do articles on a lot of our
stories and we try to add a little bit
more information for you to digest so go
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next time oh by the way
I am on my holidays and you know it's my
Caravan there you go my bed I'm actually
I'm actually in bed
see you
[Music]
guys